Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Zip Code is brought to you by me undies.
If I'm not going commando,
I'm in Biondi is,
I have been testing these underwear for three to four months now pretty much
every day and in fact throughout bunch of my other underwear this morning and on
the road in the house,
they are extremely comfortable.
They look good,
feel good.
They are made of micro modal,
two times softer than cotton as scientifically tested using the call method.
Sounds very fancy of course,
and I get a lot of compliments from ladies for these.
You don't get diaper butt,
you don't get the tired elastic band.
They look great and they have underwear for both men and women.
Check out [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim and you can see everything that
I've been wearing.
They're ridiculous to the sublime.
Everything in between,
including my favorite,
which is called out.
And I would be remiss if I didn't mention their lounge pants.
This is a new thing and I've been wearing their lounge pants when I record
podcast.
I've been wearing them out and about when I'm walking the dog meeting people for
coffee and they are extremely comfortable though.
They're made from the same material as the underwear,
but some of them like the blue ones,
I have have pockets so you can walk about without seeming like you're off of
your meds and completely crazy.
So that is awesome.
And if you're not happy with the first pair you try on,
I assume that the first of the underwear,
they'll refund you completely and you can keep the pair you tried on for free.
But if you're that kind of person,
you should be ashamed because that's disgusting.
Uh,
Mandy's dot com four slash Tim,
check it out.
This episode is brought to you by Wealthfront and this is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive in a good way.
Set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars under management.
In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why?
Why is it so popular?
Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them.
And this is because they use smarter software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams,
et cetera.
And I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz,
which only takes two to five minutes and they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they'd put you in.
And if you just want to take their advice,
run with it,
do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it.
And here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the automation of habits and strategies that
investors should using on a regular basis but normally aren't.
Great investing is a marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may or may not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of time.
Wealthfront,
as I mentioned,
since it's using software instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low costs that were previously completely
impossible right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above the first 15,000 which is managed for
free.
If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim that is less than $5 a month to invest a
$30,000 account,
for instance.
Now,
normally when I have a sponsor on this show is because I use them and recommend
them.
In this case,
it's a little different.
I don't use Wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed to.
Here's the deal,
they wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of sec regulations,
companies that invest your money are not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user end have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by wealth front that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money,
at least for me,
uh,
in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if you decide to open an account,
but just start with seeing the portfolio that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes,
fill out their questionnaire@wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim It's fast,
it's free.
There's no downside that I can think of.
Just take a look,
see what portfolio they would create for you and you can use that information
however you want.
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim
fuss,
get lawyers like cute little darlings.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
each episode,
it is my job to deconstruct world class performers from many different worlds,
whether they come from military entertainment,
sports or otherwise,
to dissect and to collect the patterns for you that you can use to tease out the
routines,
habits,
thought processes,
et Cetera,
that you can apply immediately in test in your own life.
And this episode is a really fun one.
Ever since episode two of the podcast,
we're probably around 140 or 150 now you've been asking for around two a follow
up with Josh Waitzkin and this is it.
Josh Waitzkin was the basis for the book and movie searching for Bobby Fischer.
He is considered a chess prodigy,
although we'll discuss why that term doesn't necessarily apply to him because he
has perfected learning strategies that can be applied to anything including his
loves of Brazilian Jujitsu.
He's a black belt under the fee nom nine time world champion Marcella Garcia or
Tai Chi,
push hands.
He's a world champion these days.
He spends his time coaching the world's top performers,
whether mark,
Messier,
cal Ripken,
jr or investors whose names you'd recognize or whose assets under management
would blow your mind.
And,
uh,
it's context.
I initially met Josh through his incredible book,
the art of learning,
which I love so much that I helped produce the audio book.
You can find that as part of my book club,
audible.com forward slash Tim's books in this episode is deep.
Josh has always deep and he walks the talk in the best way possible.
I hope it will blow your mind.
We talk about flow achieving flow states near death experiences,
use of slack,
line training,
elite performers,
cultivating sensitivity.
And I don't mean that in the,
the,
uh,
the most woo way imaginable,
rather the most practical way imaginable,
using heart rate variability training,
high intensity interval training,
breath awareness,
et Cetera,
uh,
intuition and its applications to investing.
And it just goes on and on and on.
So please enjoy my conversation with Josh Waitzkin.
Joshua.
Yes,
Timbo.
Welcome back buddy.
I'm so happy to be here.
I'm thrilled you're here,
man.
Hang in with you.
And I thought we could maybe start just with a complete non sequitur,
which is a book you just mentioned to me that I know nothing about,
which is dreaming yourself awake.
Can you talk about this?
Oh,
he's in the,
we're going to begin here.
It's a book that I explored a couple of years ago.
Uh,
20 years ago I started studying Tibetan Dream Yoga and lucid dreaming,
not deeply,
but exploring.
Um,
and this was during the period where I was first getting involved with my study
of East Asian philosophy.
Um,
and then a dear friend of mine recommended this book.
it's actually funny because it was a,
it was a,
we kind of made a mistake together.
I recommended another book that he texted back confirming that it was the name.
He texts me back that name that I didn't intend,
but then I picked up and read and it was extraordinary.
It's just a phenomenal discussion.
Um,
very systematic discussion of the art of lucid dreaming,
um,
in this way that fuses East Asian,
philosophy with western science.
When you were competing then at the time or were you not compete?
You were,
you were in the midst of competition two years ago you mean?
Oh,
oh,
this was two years ago.
20 years ago.
20 years ago was when I started studying he station.
Yeah,
philosophy.
I got it and I was competing in chess then.
And then the martial arts.
I need a little more caffeine.
You've had a rough night
and I want to thank you.
I'm just,
this is like 10 stream of consciousness podcast intro,
the,
we're looking at a slack line.
This is an indoor gibbon.
Classic.
Slack is,
it's about 12.
Uh,
no,
not even 10 feet long.
Maybe.
We have it surrounded by kettlebells.
Endo Board and they trust Sarah tops,
which I don't think is yours.
Got the Bosu ball there and the Bosu ball and that.
I wanted to thank you for actually getting me to bite the bullet and grab a
slackline,
which I set up on long island.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I've loved,
I've had some fun on,
on your slack line on long island too.
I love all right now I'm,
I'm in the period,
I kind of oscillate between these and my son Jack was four and a half.
We have a great time.
I'm on the Endo Board,
rock [inaudible].
He's on the Bosu Ball.
We're having a catch back and forth while on these things.
We're always integrating these interesting kinds of physiological awareness
training.
Speaking of which,
I feel like maybe we should throw a cautionary tale into this followup podcasts.
So we obviously trade stories and findings all the time.
Would you like to talk about your recent experience with Wim Hoff and breathing
training?
Wow.
Yeah.
Well I had an extremely scary experience.
Um,
so I'm a lifetime meditator and kind of
experimental subject like yourself around all these things.
Uh,
when you,
you tend to have better self preservation instinct into all the way that a lot
of close calls in life.
Well,
I had,
uh,
I,
when I heard you speak to,
um,
whim,
I was extremely intrigued actually when I heard someone mentioned him to you on
your podcast and then we spoke about it.
Then you spoke to him.
I thought he sounded like a fascinating guy.
I started digging into his work.
I,
um,
so powerful and I started doing,
he's going through his course is online course.
I loved it.
I mean the energetic feeling.
Um,
the electric surging through the body.
Uh,
I'm also a lifetime free diver since I was four or five years old.
I've been free diving and so breath hold,
just put that in perspective.
And you spend about a month,
a year,
yeah.
In the water.
Used to be,
it used to be three months when I was younger.
Um,
now it's about,
well yeah,
free dive dive in usually about a month of the year,
but I spent a lot of time now as we know,
you know,
Surfing Santa Paddle surfing,
swimming,
diving.
I mean the ocean's a huge part of my life.
We got to talk about our standup paddle adventure skill levels are pretty
hilarious.
Definitely come to that demo and I have been having some fun with that.
Um,
but I started playing with the Wim Hoff method and I thought it was incredibly
powerful.
The,
the intensity that you're experiencing internally.
It's very similar to training and touchy,
Touchy Twan moving meditation for 10,
15,
20 years and then being an hour long into a session and you have this feeling of
energetic flow inside your body with the Wim Hoff,
you'd do,
you know,
a few rounds of his breath method and you're experiencing these things.
And it was incredible that the gain and strength were mind boggling.
The length of the breath holds were fascinating.
Um,
but then I made a big technical error.
I ignored all the signs,
um,
on women's site and that you spoke about,
don't do not do this in water,
which is they were all over the place.
But I thought,
you know,
free diving is a way of life for me.
No problem.
And the major technical error was not realizing,
which is absurd after a lifetime of free diving,
that it's carbon dioxide built up that gives you the urge to breathe and not
oxygen deprivation.
Um,
hugely important thing.
Please everyone burn that in its CEO to build up that makes you want to breathe.
And so I did the after a long swim at the Nyu pool if he wants to go.
I started doing,
um,
I when breathing and did a series of underwater swims.
I did about eight 25 meter swims and I think I was on my fourth 50 and I
underwater and I um,
this was after a long workout and I went from this ecstatic state to
unconsciousness and I was actually on the bottom of the pool after blacking out
from shallow water blackout for three minutes before someone pulled me out.
And you know,
the doctors had told me,
usually it's 40 seconds to a minute to um,
perhaps permanent brain damage,
death.
I got very lucky my body saved my life and they said that if I hadn't been off
all the training I've done for so many years,
I would have been gone in more specifically.
You correct me if I'm wrong,
you didn't in,
this strikes me as so odd.
You didn't have the reflexive inhalation of water,
is that right?
Yeah,
I didn't take it and take any water into my lungs,
which is hugely fortunate because fresh water in the lungs can be,
can be terrible.
Um,
so my lungs had no water in it pretty much after they pulled me out,
I was unconscious for 25 minutes.
I have started reading on my own though when it came to 25 minutes later and I
was blue everywhere else.
My body sent all my,
all the blood to my brain and my heart saved my life and I'm here.
Um,
and it's been,
it was a life changer and a lot of levels,
you know,
the idea of my four year old boy,
four blocks away,
sitting on the rug waiting for daddy to come home and me on unconscious in the
bottom of a pool blue.
Just that's the kind of experience that I'm shattering.
How did that change how you think about training in these types of experiments
or life in general?
I know it's a very broad question,
but I,
I've been,
how does it change your decision making?
Because,
yeah.
Well,
first of all,
how it's influenced my life in general is I've,
I've never lived with such a consistent sense of gratitude,
beauty,
and love in my,
in my life.
It's just flowing through my body presence to the exquisite little ripples of
beauty in everything I do.
Um,
and a sense of gratitude for the little things.
It sounds Cliche,
but it's embodied and I really feel it.
Um,
and in terms of,
and,
and that's,
uh,
that's,
something I'm really grateful for.
It's exquisite.
I've,
uh,
you know,
my little boy,
my wife is pregnant with,
we have another,
another sun coming in June.
Um,
and it's made me rethink this questions of risk
and it,
but on the other hand,
it's very important,
not that oversteer I mean,
one of the most important learning lessons that I've learned for myself and the
training elite mental performer is,
is,
is people oversee all the time.
They over calibrate.
And so,
um,
I've been very careful to sit with this and try to draw the right lessons out of
it.
Not The wrong,
um,
and not too big a lesson and not too small lesson.
So,
for example,
this was a huge technical oversight I had.
I didn't realize I was taking a big risk here.
If a lot of big risks that I've taken in life,
um,
it's,
I'm with you.
Um,
and I think I'm actually pretty good at navigating those of,
but em,
but I've been thinking about them quite a bit and of course,
cognizant of the level of danger,
right?
Risk,
But of course it's very important for me to be cognizant,
like in a group risk as we've discussed,
it's important to be presence,
your own level and the level of everyone else around you.
Um,
we can get into some of those towels,
get into that.
Um,
but I've been really sitting with this,
you know,
since I was a really young boy,
I started playing chess when I was six years old.
By the time I was seven,
I was the top ranked player.
So I had in the country.
So I had all this pressure on me and a big part of the way that I found my
therapy was flow.
Can you expand that?
Yeah.
Like when I was under huge pressure,
external pressure for a little boy,
you know,
my style is a chess player,
was to create chaos.
I love the game.
I love the battle of chest attacking chess,
right,
right.
Attacking chest,
uh,
and,
and most players w you know,
when they have a lot of pressure on them in the scholastic chess world,
for example,
in the shoe,
in many fields,
they learn how to memorize their way to victory,
right?
And they find shortcuts to getting good fast and be controlling the game all the
way.
I think about reading points to think about rankings.
They think about winning.
They have parental pressures,
they have,
you know,
school pressures.
They have sometimes publicity pressures if they're doing well.
So they want to control their way.
I had a different approach.
I like to mix it up.
I like to,
to,
you know,
I grew up playing in Washington square park with the hustlers who taught me to,
to battle.
It fit my personality.
And it was,
you know,
a core part of my competitive style to create chaos and find hidden harmonies
and find flow in chaos.
And as I've reflected on this in recent years,
a big part of how I've dealt with stresses has been to put myself into a flow
state.
Um,
and this is a really an element of risk that I've been,
I've been thinking about it.
It's,
it's different when you're 20 and 25 and 30 years old as a professional
competitor or professional fighter.
Um,
and then,
you know,
now I'm 39 years old dad,
which is the most important thing I've ever done in my life,
being a father and I'm so committed to it.
Um,
so I have to be quite cognizant of,
of the distinction.
For example,
between between risk competitively and risk.
Mortally,
when you're playing chess,
it feels like life and death.
It really does feel like life and death.
When you lose a chess game,
it feels like you've been shattered on the most fundamental level.
And so I was quite comfortable mixing it up,
um,
profoundly creating chaos and,
and I'd be willing to take those risks,
but actually it isn't life and death.
Right.
And then when you're a professional fighter or martial artist,
you are,
you,
you know,
you can break arms and legs in a second if you're,
if you're not in deep focus or you can break your neck.
But again,
the stakes are,
it's you out there,
right?
And then when you're a dad,
it's a little bit different,
right?
Then like when you're surfing or when you're rock climbing or whatever,
you're doing it to an extreme state.
Um,
so it's very important for me to be clear about the distinction between what
felt like life and death is a chess player and what actually is life and death
and f Oracle and literal.
Right.
And then there's the state of being,
um,
someone who's found deep flow as the ultimate therapy.
How do you,
there are number of different questions I want to ask for later to everything
you just said.
The first is how do you initiate or facilitate a flow state and how would you
describe it?
Maybe we could hit that first.
Well,
I've had a lot of different ways of playing this over the years for me.
So I mean,
I can relate.
I can describe it in terms of myself and I can then we can go into how when I
train people how I'd work with them.
Great.
Um,
for me love has been a huge part of flow.
You know,
I fell in love with chess and I found flow in the self expression of,
um,
through an art form that I,
that I absolutely loved.
And I think this is really important with children,
right?
To,
to find something that they feel just connected to and that they can express
themselves through.
They can bring out the essence of their being through some art.
Um,
and then there was a tremendous competitive intensity.
And of course,
stretching yourself to your limit is a huge part of it.
It's a very important precondition to,
to flow.
And I was always playing as people who were at my level or above.
And so I was,
I was stretched,
right?
Um,
and then I was integrating in,
in my teenage years,
start integrating meditation into my practice,
right?
So I got very good at,
at increasing my somatic awareness,
my physiological,
introspective sensitivity.
I began to feel the subtle ripples of quality in my process.
I could feel when I moved from a nine or a 10 out of 10 down to back down to a
nine or an eight.
You're talking about in the meditation itself,
that was only in like through my meditation practice,
you became more tactically sensitive when doing push hands or some other type of
practice,
chess initially chest and then into push hands.
Right.
Why is the tactile component important in chess?
I think it's hugely important,
um,
in mental disciplines.
So for example,
you know,
in chess and today a lot of what I do today is,
is have this laboratory of training.
Elite mental performer is largely in finance investors and I'm a huge part of
the training is in their physiological introspective sensitivity.
It's,
that's the sematic awareness.
That's the foundational training.
Why?
Well,
first of all,
you know,
we can't just separate our mind in our body.
Totally.
Um,
I mean,
you heart tesion duality,
right?
I mean,
this is your way of life as well,
but we intuitively can feel things way before we are consciously aware of them.
All right,
the chess player always senses danger before he sees it.
Just like you know,
the hunter will sense the shark with the Jaguar before you'll see it,
right?
Then he'll look for it.
So the chess players processes often to be studying a position to sense
opportunity or danger and then to start looking for it,
right?
Deconstruct what it is and then find what it probably is and that's our
calculating,
right?
But that sends comes before or if you're a great decision maker,
if you're an investor,
you can sense danger,
right?
You can sense opportunity,
but you need to have stilled your waters internally to feel the,
like the subtle changes inside of you.
That would be opportunity or the crystallization of complex ideas,
um,
or danger or onset of a cognitive bias,
for example,
which is hugely important as a chess player or as an investor or is anything
else you,
you know,
this is one of the areas where I,
we've had this ongoing dialogue and our friendship around what I call armchair
professors,
right?
Um,
Velocify ologists right?
Philosophy.
Politics.
Yes.
So the people,
this is a philosophy,
soldiers is a term of um,
Robert Pirsig is the author of Zen in the art of motorcycle maintenance is one
of my favorite books and thinkers,
friend of mine.
Um,
okay.
You know the difference between the philosopher and the philosophy.
I'll just,
is what Tim is referring to.
Um,
or the writer and the literary critic or the man in the arena and the arms or
professor
or Remy from Ratatouille and Antonio.
Okay.
I don't know that one.
Food critic.
Okay.
Yeah,
there it is.
Good.
Yes,
there it is.
And so when we think about for example,
cognitive biases,
the people,
the,
the academics who study cognitive biases who speak about them in mind
and just for people who have no context on cognitive biases and example to like
the sunk cost fallacy,
right?
I've spent this amount,
therefore I should put good money after bad because I feel like I have,
I need to somehow try to salvage this money that I've put into a given position.
Right?
I just wanted to give people some examples.
Who,
who,
um,
we've had a number of meals with them.
Uh,
there's a gent wouldn't think twice.
What was the author's name again?
Do you recall?
Mabou son?
Yeah.
Michael Bovis in is or your thing isn't there?
We are for people interested.
Sorry to interrupt.
Yup.
Um,
and so one of the interesting things about,
about the dialogue,
the academic dialogue of cognitive biases is that there's the idea that the eye,
the biases have to operate completely separately from the intuitive process,
right?
As if we have an intuitive process and then we have to go through a checklist of
cognitive biases.
In my experience,
really high level thinkers have integrated cognitive biases or an awareness of
cognitive bias.
He's into their,
into intuitive process,
right?
So this is constant process.
We discussed this,
we just got this a couple years ago actually.
Um,
yeah,
where you're,
you're deconstructing technical awareness into something that,
and so this process,
for example,
of,
of building a pyramid of knowledge,
we have a certain technical foundation.
We have a high level intuitive leap.
We can then deconstruct the intuitive leap into something that we can understand
technically and replicate technically and then we are raising our foundation of
higher and higher level intuitive leaps,
right?
This is this pyramid of knowledge,
which in my,
in my process is built upon by the intuitive leaps are what's guiding it.
Similarly,
we can learn how to take technical material and integrate it into our intuitive
understanding,
but we aren't going to intuit the cognitive bias.
We're going to intuit the feeling then that corresponds the corresponds with a
bias being present.
And so we think about this relative to the language.
Again,
Robert Pirsig,
I liked the language of dynamic versus static quality,
right?
When you're,
if you think about the timeline in a competitive state for in a chess game,
there's a certain objective truth to a chest position.
If we go that is a timeline which is moving,
um,
which is moving,
I think our a six term of being at the front of the freight train of reality,
right?
Freight train is pushing through dynamic qualities right at the front of that
freight train,
right?
Think about that as a timeline and then the,
those are the chess,
the chess players mind studying the position.
When the chess players present to the position,
it's continuing,
right?
You're,
you're,
you're just running parallel to the truth of the position to,
they didn't have the quality of the position,
but if let's say something changes,
you make a slight mistake,
you move from having a slight advantage to us like disadvantage,
but you are emotionally still connected,
attached to having a slight advantage.
Then what's going to happen is that you are sort of stopping your dinette,
your dynamic qualities becoming a static,
but the timeline of the suspicions,
continuing the Games continuing.
But what's going to happen then is it,
you're going to subtly reject positions that you should accept and you're going
to stretch for positions that you can't,
for evaluations that you can't really reach and you're going to fall into a
downward spiral.
So that's,
that's the onset of a cognitive bias.
In that case,
the cognitive bias would,
would relate to to the emotional clinging to a past evaluation.
But if you had the present state awareness,
which you had trained through different tools and approaches that you use with
easily performers,
for instance,
you would,
you would have,
you would sense the feeling of that cognitive dissonance and not get caught up
in sort of the slipstream of that
dislocation.
Exactly.
And the way that you would sense that in this case is that you would feel the
slip away from dynamic quality.
Right?
And so,
and then you would deconstruct that feeling and then you would see what the
biases at setting it.
So this is,
this is really important to to to say,
right?
It's not that we're going to intuitively develop the ability to know exactly
what bias might be setting in in the moment,
but we're going to cultivate the ability to have presence.
Right?
I think about they'd have cultivating qualities,
a way of life,
cultivating presence as a way of life in little moments and small and we're
holding our babies when we're reading a book,
when we're having a conversation with a friend when we're meditating.
How do you help
people to identify what that feeling to become more sensitized to it?
And just as a,
as a,
maybe not a counter example,
but an example of not listening to intuition or instinct.
So we were both in Costa Rica recently and doing paddle boarding last week,
last meal of the trip,
uh,
we,
we go out to celebrate,
we go to this seafood restaurant,
food comes out,
it's a Sunday.
And I leaned over the plate and smelled the food and immediately knew that it
was something I shouldn't eat.
And despite that,
you know,
everybody's ordering drinks,
everybody's celebrating,
went into the food.
And about a third of the way through I stopped and I just push the plate away.
And then lo and behold,
everybody gets severe severe food poisoning except for the two people who,
I guess we tried to narrow it down to whether it was the garlic dip or any
number of other things.
But yeah,
we were,
we were on the toilet each like every five minutes for,
for the next 12 hours minimum.
And the great part of it is you and I were,
we were joining veterans.
We were sharing the same toilet.
So that was a hell of
a night and we never saw each other.
It was amazing.
But I heard that flushing happening,
taking turns.
That was,
that was a brutal experience.
I remember watching you sniffing,
you had this like expression of concern come over you at the dinner table.
And like I saw that moment,
maybe I wasn't present enough to you and you didn't.
It's a great example of you didn't fully trust your gut,
but you were right on is amazing.
Before I've felt a sort of social pressure to conform and not rock the boat.
So how do you help someone say in the world of investing just as an example,
develop,
not only develop the sensitivity to,
to separate that signal from the noise,
but also to actually listen to it,
right?
Uh,
yeah,
these are,
these are two,
two different points,
right?
So,
right.
So let's talk about developing it and let's talk about listening to it,
right?
Because there's both.
So hugely important.
And I'd frame them both thematically,
um,
in,
in different ways.
And I'd build training systems around them,
both.
It would be quite different.
So when we're thinking about,
about cultivating the awareness,
I mean I think that a lot of this relates to a return to a more natural state,
right?
The,
this isn't so much about learning as unlearning agreed to getting out of our own
way.
Releasing obstructions.
I think about the training process is the movement would unobstructed self
expression,
right?
Obstructed Nis.
Um,
we have so many habits that are fundamentally blocking us right from the phone.
Addictions.
Um,
people are constantly distracted.
People don't have the ability to sit in empty space anymore.
People are bombarded by inputs all the time.
They're in a constantly reactive state.
So one way that you could frame this out as is cultivating a way of life,
which is fundamentally proactive,
right?
In little things and big and you can build day architectures that are
fundamentally proactive.
But then getting into the,
the,
the weeds a little bit more.
I think it's most foundational to develop a mindfulness practice to cultivate
the ability to sense the most subtle ripples of human experience.
Now,
I've been trying to onboard people in specifically in the,
in the finance space,
for example,
in the meditation for a bit over eight years.
Now.
Initially I would just try to get up guys to meditate and look at me like I was
crazy.
Then what I realized,
I had this breakthrough,
which was that if I had them start doing stress and recovery interval training,
then when,
so oscillating heart rate between one seventies and one 40 say,
um,
so let's say someone does a six or eight or 10 minute warm up and then they're
on a heart rate interval doing some kind of cardio bike or whatever,
moving their heart rate up a number two,
one 71 41 to become aware of the quality of their focus on their breath during
the recovery intervals,
um,
enhancing their ability to lower their heart rate more quickly and they start to
feel their heart rates listened to it.
When that awareness we're kicking,
I'd start,
I'd layer and meditation and the onramp was just much more successful.
People would just,
and then what I started to refine that with is is biofeedback,
so now what I'll do is I'll have them do the stress recovery interval training.
Then I'll have them do some form of biofeedback often with for example,
heart variability through heart math and working with a specialist and then when
they begin to have a certain kind of consistency of their ability to observe,
to enhance their emotional regulation to observe these subtle ripples between
stress and coherence and you can see their biometric data.
Then you layer in meditation and then the,
the onramp is even more powerful and so then they embedded layer in a meditation
practice.
I think headspace is a wonderful tool for Larry and repetition and I think for a
lot of people.
Also starting with headspace before bed is another kind of gateway drug approach
to then building into our leading into the morning meditation,
which a lot of people have trouble with because they wake up,
they feel rushed.
It's another thing to layer in on top of the brushing the teeth and getting the
kids ready,
et cetera.
And so sometimes the evening approached,
but I agreed that had spaces really useful.
And I think it's really important,
I think.
I think you're absolutely right there.
And I think it's really important to have a core meditation practice,
which is at least in the beginning,
in case in the conditions in your life that are most conducive to deep focus and
to not be distracted later in life.
We wanna be able to tap our meditation under complete and in chaos,
but we want to cultivate it initially in the most peaceful time possible.
If you have kids waking up before the kids,
um,
are up or in the evening,
once they're asleep or if you don't have kids,
then life is much simpler.
Or during your commute.
I've found a lot of people who will just like throw on headspace or some song
that they meditate too and they know they have 20 minutes on the subway.
It's like,
all right,
that's my 20 minutes.
Right?
Um,
yeah,
I enjoy meditating on the commute a lot.
Personally,
W W you've been meditating for a long time.
I mean,
what,
I'm not sure how you feel about this.
I find that if people can have the first two,
three months of meditation practice in a quiet room,
then if they start doing it in their commute,
it's a much,
and they've,
they've sort of built the foundation of it in this really quiet space.
I think.
I think that,
from what I can tell,
it appears to depend a lot on what type of concentrator you are.
And what I mean by that is if you look at writers,
for instance,
there's some writers who want to be in a quiet environment in order to hear
whatever the Muse is whispering,
and they'll go to a library,
they'll go to someplace like that.
I can't do that for whatever reason.
I thrive in noisy environments because if I have the noise,
I feel like it focuses me.
It forces me to focus inward.
So for me,
uh,
studying languages,
even in a loud environment,
writing in a loud environment,
uh,
for whatever reason is a forcing function for me.
But I can definitely see why for even perhaps a majority of people it would be,
I think it's partially due to the fact that,
for instance,
I'm looking at your wall right now and the fact that that picture is tilted like
five degrees to the right is making me totally bonkers.
You think we should fix,
we fix it.
This is training for the rest of the time was always your therapy.
But the,
the,
the same is true.
Auditorially.
So if I have a controlled noise like music or the,
the Chica to Dick Jackets of the,
of the car in the subway,
I can focus on that repetitive noise.
But if I'm sitting in a space that I want to be quiet and I have that
controlling aspect of my personality trying to impose itself on something I
can't control.
And then there's like somebody's hitting reverse in a truck and I can hear that
outside.
It will drive you nuts.
Uh,
long observation to a short comment.
But,
uh,
I do think that if you can drop in,
in a quiet environment,
the point being,
as you said,
I think to stack the deck in the beginning.
Yeah.
Like learn how to do this in a controlled unstressful environment and then you
can ratchet up over time to when you can use it in the most stressful of
environments,
right?
Because we don't ultimately want to be meditating and flower garden.
We want to be able to meditate and have a meditative state throughout our life
in a hurricane and a thunder storm.
Um,
you know,
and when sharks are attacking you at any moment,
cause that's paddleboarding.
When you paddle boarding the last day on a first trip and Josh his leg,
you'll be fine.
And then three leashes snap and all hell breaks loose.
That's a long story.
It killers that comes in.
So that's just a little context here.
Timbo and I have been on this great adventure.
Um,
the stand up paddle surfing,
taking it on together.
And we found this,
we've got a great friend down in Costa Rica,
Eric Anderson,
who I'm actually as the,
the other other podcasts other than yours.
They listened to him.
I have the paddle Luca potato paddle.
Eric's awesome.
He's a great dude.
You're on the blue zones up.
He's a brilliant teacher.
Um,
really fascinating mind deconstructing standup paddle surfing on increasingly
small boards for us.
And we've been going out there and we've had some hilarious close calls.
The last trip a couple of weeks ago,
we almost,
we had,
we almost destroyed each other.
Yeah.
We had this one like witching hour where the g the Juju is really weird.
Almost everybody either getting to capitated impaled by a board or just head on
Justin collision,
which is what,
but the point that you bring up,
I think is,
is right on about meditation.
That,
that,
you know,
when you're building training programs for elite mental performers,
the most important thing is to understand them so deeply and build programs that
are unique to their,
to their funk,
embraced their funk.
Um,
that's a term my buddy Graham,
who's a,
who's a dear friend of ours,
who's comes on our surf adventures with us.
Um,
he said,
brilliant thought partner.
Um,
embrace the funk.
Could you explain that?
Yeah.
We have to embrace our funk.
We have to figure out what,
you know,
you think about the,
the entanglement of genius and madness,
right?
Or Brilliance and eccentricity.
Understanding that entanglement is always a precursor working with anybody who's
trying to be world class at something because that entanglement is fundamental
to their being.
And they have to ultimately embraced,
embraced their funk,
embrace their eccentricity,
embrace what makes them different,
um,
and then build on it,
right?
And we shall,
we think about self expression.
It's not trying to take everyone and put them into the same mold as trying to
understand someone very deeply in build a training program,
a way of life.
Um,
that helps them bring out the essence of their being through their art,
whatever their art is.
I mean,
then that's how I relate to the path to excellence in chess and martial arts,
in,
in different arts,
in very actively.
In the investing space.
When I work in education with children,
um,
through a nonprofit,
it's,
it's again that the movement,
um,
set to unobstructed self expression,
but,
but the problem is that teachers don't listen.
They don't know how to listen,
right?
They don't know how to sit or parents to sit in an empty space and observe the
nuance of their child's mind where their students Mont and then build a way of
life around that.
They,
they,
people are used to teach them the way they learned.
They got martial arts instructors,
almost all of them trained a certain way and then teach that way,
which alienates 65,
70% of the students.
By definition.
It's very rare that you have someone who can take the time to,
and it takes a lot of time to know someone deeply enough to build a training
program in a way of life around who they are.
I mean,
for me and what I only work with,
with eight teams and I don't take on new clients,
very seldom.
I take on a new client and I won't work with more than eight people.
You also don't do a lot of PR for everybody listening.
I always get these emails and texts like,
Hey,
could you intro me to Josh of my show?
And I'm like,
he's not,
he's not going to do it.
Jim,
you're the only person once a year or two,
I either one guy who brings me out of my,
her medicaid,
if I live a bit of a strange life because I'm not on a strict,
doesn't feel strange to me.
It feels completely natural.
But I am not on Facebook or Twitter or Instagram or any of these things.
I don't even know the names of most of them.
I have an email account though.
Do you have that?
Um,
bought straight.
I cultivate empty space as a way of life for,
for um,
for the creative process.
So Timbo,
you're the one guy who brings me out of the cave where we had a lot of fun
together.
You're talking about these top performers and getting to know them on a very
deep,
subtle level so that you can help them express that,
the combination of their madness and genius or at least embrace it among other
things.
How do you think about parenting?
Yeah,
let's dig into this one.
Um,
all right,
so,
and then let's look,
remember loop,
bag after this cause we to finish this discussion of,
first of all we were talking about how to cultivate the sematic awareness and
then how to listen to it.
Let's go back to that.
A train to listen to it.
Um,
okay.
Parenting Jack.
Well,
Jack's the love of my life.
I mean this kid is such an awesome dude and I parenting has,
um,
has been the most fantastic learning experience I've ever gone through.
So from when he was born I,
I tried very hard not to go in with a,
with a lot of preconceived ideas and to be attuned to him,
to listen to him from when he was just days,
weeks old.
He was teaching me,
you know,
you talk about teaching presence,
W W we,
our eyes would be connected and if I would think about something else,
he would,
his eyes would pull me back if he,
if there was any distraction and said,
and he would pull me back and he's got a little older,
he would just take your face in my face and pull it back,
um,
in the sweetest way.
And so the depth of connection,
you know,
being deeply attuned to a young spirit that hasn't become blocked,
that isn't that state of unobstructed self expression,
that is just this unbelievably game learner,
unblocked learner.
And Jack is the game.
This little person I've ever known in my life.
Um,
and so,
but,
but I,
of course I have been thinking about learning and education for lot of years and
so I had some,
some thoughts.
And so for example,
I think that control is the need for control is something that inhibits people
in life.
The need to have external conditions be just so,
and in order for them to be able to,
um,
Timo is pointing at the,
at my grandmother's painting,
that was my grandma's painting.
It's a beauty,
right?
That's great.
Stella,
Stella Waitzkin chess.
That's,
that's her self portrait.
Okay.
We're going to leave it messed up.
We're working on control.
So like from one,
a young age for me I,
but when I started playing chess I would create the cast and the board like I
described and then I would play in,
in chess shops with people blowing smoke and playing music.
And I'd play chess with like loud butoh monk chance bursting into,
you know,
in my head from speakers I would,
when I play cards I would never plan things you normally,
I'd always keep the melds out of order so that again,
when I would play cards I parents like a on card card game playing like Gin
rummy.
I would never organize my hand.
I'd always keep it Usaf Meld.
Yeah.
Like if you have like three sevens,
right?
Or like,
all right,
Jack Queen,
Jacqueline,
queen of [inaudible].
I would keep everything out of order,
so I'd have to reorganize it in my mind.
I'd keep my room messy.
So you wouldn't gather your IC,
you wouldn't,
you wouldn't move your cards around to organized.
Right.
I was creating chaos everywhere to train at being able to be at peace in chaos
and organize things in it.
That was kind of part of my way of life and I found it to be a huge advantage
that I had competitively.
And so one thing,
one of the biggest mistakes that I observed in the first year of Jack's life,
we are two objective that I observed with parents is that they do have this
language around weather,
whether being good or bad.
And whenever the weather,
when it was raining,
they'd be like,
it's bad weather you here.
You know,
mom's babysitters.
Dad's talking about if it's bad weather,
we can't go out or it's good weather we can go out.
And so that means that somehow we're externally reliant on conditions being
perfect in order to be able to go out and have a good time.
So Jack and I never missed a single storm.
Every rainstorm.
I don't think we,
I don't think we've missed one storm
other than maybe one when he was sick,
but we,
I don't think we've,
I don't think we've missed a single storm rain or snow going outside and romping
it.
And we've developed this language around how beautiful it was.
And so when,
now whenever there's a rainy day,
Jack says,
look,
that adds such a beautiful rainy day and we go out and we play in it.
And you know,
I wanted him to have this internal locus of control,
right,
to not be reliant on external conditions being just so,
and then that kind of has,
now he's four,
he's getting older as we've been playing with these things,
we began meditating together when he was a little over a year just doing breath
work.
Initially we started doing meditation work when he was in that kind of most pure
state.
So when he'd be taking a warm bath and he was lying on his back and being
completely relaxed,
blissed out,
we would just naturally breathe together.
I wanted the habit to be formed in something that was the initial experience to
be in conditions that are most conducive to just natural piece.
Um,
and then we have in recent months been taking it to an interesting funky place.
So,
so he was watching me do the Wim Hoff training and I'd be putting my hands in
ice buckets and doing this interesting breathwork through cold water and he
would initially watching to come over to stick his finger in,
put his hand in two.
This is a great moment.
A couple months ago we were out romping in this huge snow storm and Jack about
10 minutes into it,
we just gone this long search for the right carrot to put on it to make a
snowman with.
We found that the nose,
we found it and then Jack got,
he was in this huge drift and he got his boots just load it up with snow and he
looked at me and he said,
Dad,
dad,
my,
my feet are cold,
they're filled with my boots are filled with snow.
But that's okay.
I'll just do the Wim Hoff and make them warm.
And has looked at him and then he,
for an hour and a half,
we played after that feet just covered with snow and he was completely fine.
Never mentioned it again.
And then he got increasingly interested in,
in this internal terrain and we would take hot baths together.
We take a bath together every night and then he would want to turn on the cold
shower and get in it.
And he would,
we'd play what we call the,
it's a good game.
And so we kind of reframe this thing,
you know,
I,
I have this,
you know,
people tend to bounce off of discomfort,
whether it's mental or physical.
And so they run up at whether,
if they're running to internal resistance,
whether it's a meditation training or someone exposing a weakness,
or if there are training and someone might be better than them,
whatever,
whatever it is,
they bounce away from things that might expose them,
they're repelled from it.
Right,
right.
And,
but you know,
the flip side of this is to learn the way I,
you I talk about living on the other side of pain,
pain being like mental or physical discomfort,
right?
And much of life that's so rich comes from then the other side of it.
Um,
the other set of challenge,
internal or external challenge.
And I,
with Jack of course I'm not using that,
but it's a little child's embodiment of it.
We,
we started to play with turning on the cold water and he would say it's so good
that day and we'd kind of be in a hot bath and play in the cold.
And he would say,
it's so good.
It's so good.
And he began to have this gorgeous,
blissful smile,
meditating through it.
He would,
and you know,
he would say,
I'm meditating through it.
It's so good.
And we were reframing.
Cold cold was as a metaphor from something that uses you bounce away from,
to something that you can learn to sit with,
to be neutral and to find pleasure in just like the weather.
And then we had this experience of the day where he said to me,
um,
you know,
daddy will,
you tickled me slowly.
And I always took,
let me laughs.
Uproariously but we were lying in bed and I was tickling me.
I'm very slowly,
and he was going to do my meditation.
He would meditate.
And then he said to me,
then the next day's a day that will,
you tickled me slowly.
And I did it.
And he's like to pick up a little bit faster.
And I didn't suggest as the him,
he said just it to me.
And then we played this game where we say one to 10 and I would tickle him
slowly.
So doing his meditation and we move it from one,
two and we'd go up to,
he would like we doing his meditation and finally I'd be full tilt tickling and
you'd normally be in hysterics.
And he was just sitting there meditating,
um,
and not laughing.
And he found this so interesting and he's now guiding the process in this,
in this beautiful way.
And now we're turning into talking about,
you know,
question just to interject.
Did you at any point condition him to be proactive in that way or was it just an
organic,
now I'm in the driver's seat.
I encouraged them to grab the wheel all the time.
I mean,
a huge part of my relationship to parenting,
and this is from my mom and I watched my mom with Jack and I think this is maybe
the greatest gift that my mom gave me is just having a sense of agency in the
world.
You know,
the idea that,
you know,
the having a sense that I can impact the world,
right?
And that my,
that my compass really matters.
Or it's when I grew up,
I was,
I wasn't seen but not heard.
I was familiar routes five and six years old.
They're having adult conversations with friends and are,
and I was,
I was part of it.
They wanted to hear my ideas and I felt that they mattered.
And that's a big part of how I believe in my wife and I believe in raising
check.
And so
he,
um,
he plays a really active role in everything that we do.
And so it was sort of a natural thing and it was all fun and play.
I wasn't pushing any of these things on him at all.
This is stuff that he wanted to do,
but then he,
him naturally,
I've been,
I've been kind of blown away by how he's been transferring this stuff over.
I mean lateral thinking or thematic thinking,
the ability to take a lesson from one thing and transferred over to another.
I think it was one of the most important disciplines that any of us can
cultivate or,
or ways of being.
And it's something that Jack and I have from a really young age.
We began to cultivate this from when he was really smaller on this principle of
goal around,
um,
we,
we would,
we would initially,
it was like the first thing that time happened is that he was trying,
he was really tiny.
He was trying to get in.
We're in a little cottage sing little cottage in,
uh,
in,
um,
on Martha's vineyard,
tiny little cottage in a big field.
And he was trying to get in one door and he couldn't,
but he could get in the other door.
And I said,
Jack,
go around.
And he looked at me and then he went around and then go around,
became a language for us physically.
If you can't go one way you go around another way.
But then it became a language for us in terms of solving puzzles and in terms of
any way me,
you are running an obstacle goal around and then working with the metaphor of
goal around opened up this way that we would just have dialogue around
connecting things,
right?
Taking away of a principal from one thing and applying it to something else.
And we've had a lot of fun with that.
And so it's,
it's fascinating to see you this game little dude,
if you have this dramatic dialogue,
principal driven dialogue and we're where I'm cultivating sematic awareness,
cultivating
the ability to feel these little ripples inside him.
And Jack's telling me his dreams in this beautiful way.
He tells me,
you know,
how his emotions feel in his body.
Um,
it's a great journey.
I'm learning so much from him.
There's a book you've mentioned to me a number of times,
or at the very least a researcher,
and I'm probably going to mask or this name as well as the Carol Dweck,
getting that right mindset,
Carol Dweck mindset.
Yeah,
yeah.
Fixed an entity like fixed or entity theories of intelligence versus incremental
or growth mindset.
It,
Carol Dweck,
it's one of the most important foundational developmental psychologist I think
around around this distinction of a fixed perspective on how good somebody is.
You know,
let's,
let's frame it like this.
Most children unfortunately are educated to believe that they have a certain
ingrained level of ability in things.
You are smart,
you are dumb,
you are average,
right?
And they're told,
and the sad thing is that when they are [inaudible] w when even when they're
praised,
they're told how smart they are,
right?
Or you're such a good writer,
You're such a,
you're so good at math or,
and the kids will say,
I'm smart at this or I'm dumb at that.
Right?
And so,
but if you're a very smart at one thing,
then that means that if you fail,
then you must be dumb at it.
And so it becomes very static,
right?
W and the kids are often quite brittle when they have a fixed mindset,
Or an entity theory of intelligence.
Well,
a growth mindset or mastery oriented mindset is one where we understand that our
are,
the path to mastery involves incremental growth,
right?
We were not,
we don't have an end grain level of ability.
It's something we're going to have successes and failures.
We're going to work at things.
And it's,
it's,
it's work,
it's practice.
Um,
and it's an open mindedness to life experiences that makes us succeed.
How would the praise differ?
You would praise a kid for the process versus the outcome.
And so you would say,
I'm so proud of how hard you worked at your math.
Not,
you're so smart at math.
Right?
Or if someone,
if someone has a failure,
the other side of it is,
is not to say that don't worry about it.
You're just not good at math.
You'd lose something else.
It's to say,
well,
how can we practice it this to get better?
And so we're focusing on the process and not the outcome.
That's the fundamental principle.
And it's so easy to,
um,
to say it,
but it's,
it's very hard for people to,
to live it as parents,
especially if they don't embody it themselves.
What you see often with kids and parents is that the,
um,
the parents are fundamentally fixed.
They have an entity theory of intelligence themselves.
They're fixed,
they're stuck,
but they've read the material of Carol Dweck or somebody else and they want to
parent their kids around a growth mindset.
But the kids see what they embodied,
not what they say.
So we have to embody it.
I mean,
one of the most important things that we do,
I think that we do with my foundation,
um,
and our work with schools,
with programs around the world is that we,
when we're working with teachers,
it's not just this is the material you should teach your students.
It's working with these core principles and embodying it themselves first.
And then,
um,
through that embodied intelligence,
working with the kids and how they can embody it,
you have to walk the talk.
So let's,
let's go back to what you said.
She go back to at some point,
which is somatic sensitivity,
those sort of dimples of light in the darkness that most people overlook.
Uh,
how do you train that?
Well,
thematically,
the first thing I would say is that is that we need to think about cultivating
an internal locus of control or an internal orientation versus an external one,
right?
So as an artist or performer,
we have all these external pressures on us.
Let's say for example,
again,
let's talk about investors again or just say an investor is running,
uh,
a $1 billion investment vehicle and they have partners,
they have people who invest in that,
right?
And they have to write investment letters.
Um,
they have all the partners say they have 30 or 40 or 50 partners who are
institutions,
maybe endowments,
educational dominance,
charities,
whatever,
who have put their money into this investment vehicle.
And maybe that person has zone money as well.
Her own money in this investment vehicle.
Well,
for them to be successful,
they have to operate from the inside out.
They have to bring out the essence of who they are as a performer like we do.
We're discussing,
um,
or as a human being is to bring that up through their art.
But if they are constantly feeling pressured by what others expect from them,
what others want from them,
how they'll be perceived,
right.
Or you know,
how people are looking at their Facebook post or how their tweet is being
responded to.
Right.
It's tweet.
That's what it is.
I mean,
it's so interesting for me,
I like watching people watch their Instagram accounts,
right?
I see it with buddies with all the time.
It's natural.
It's,
it's completely human.
But,
but then we're,
we're aware of how we're perceived.
Right.
One of the major way reasons that I stay away from these things is because I can
feel how susceptible I am to this stuff,
right?
You publish a book and it's on Amazon.
It's so hard not to go look at the Amazon numbers,
right?
And then the bill comes out and you're tracking them.
Even if you know it's ridiculous and you shouldn't be doing it now,
someone like you,
you're still worldclass.
Um,
and you've so systematically trained at and cultivated the ability to market
these things.
This is actually a very important scientific input for you.
It's not for most authors.
Most authors is an addiction,
right?
So that's completely different point in my opinion.
You're actually gathering data and using it.
Most people are just,
just constantly feeling,
um,
tapping the vein,
right?
Tapping the vein.
So with investors with as often relates to as PNL,
checking profit and loss,
Chong.
Sure.
Right?
So most investors check P and l hundreds of times a day.
In fact,
it's constantly because it's on their screen all the time.
And so having these like little adrenal hits all the time,
right?
Whether it's dopamine or cortisol,
whether they're making money or losing money,
they're constantly bouncing off of these things.
That's the ultimate external external orientation,
right?
So if you think about about internal plus proactive versus external plus
reactive,
this is how I would tend to frame this out.
We want to build a proactive way of life that's fundamentally moved from the
inside out versus a reactive way of light.
We're co lead for constantly reacting to all of these inputs,
which we may or may not want.
Um,
and we're,
we're constantly beleaguered by or oppressed by a sense of,
of how we're going to be perceived social pressures,
right?
And so then you're talking about a really high level artist who might have a
really subtle intuition about something,
um,
and they should listen to that intuition or they should at least deconstructed
intuition and investigate it and see if it's the right way to go.
But they're aware that that intuition might not be perceived as impressive by
others.
The problem is that the others usually aren't world class artists.
They're the arms,
your professors there,
the philosophy ologists.
And so you have the man in the arena whose compromised by a census of
consciousness of what the critics are going,
how the critics are going to perceive him or her,
which is ridiculous because it's like an a player thinking about how the
approval of a c player and that's disastrous.
That's external orientation.
That's like looking at,
you know,
I mean s thinking that we have,
we're going to get food poisoning from something and something's off and I'm
thinking and then dismissing it because of,
I mean,
first of all,
there's the incredibly subtle sense is how strongly intuition is,
right?
I mean,
I that no one else had that table there and we had some pretty high level dudes
who on the table it had that feeling that that we,
we're about to eat something.
I had food poisoning,
right?
So it's very subtle.
You had a very subtle sense.
It wasn't bang you over the head.
Right.
And then there's the feeling of the social pressures and everything,
right?
It's a very interesting subtle example.
Yeah.
Right.
But it's the subtle pressures,
pressures were louder in that case.
And then like the really subtle intuition that you had.
And then there's having the attitude of,
I don't care about the social pressures,
but that's really hard.
Right.
Which I was able to do a third of the way through it,
but not before.
Right.
I think you're actually really,
you know,
and my observation,
you were really evolved with this.
I mean,
w w w I mean,
I,
um,
I mean you have so much external
pressure and external awareness on you.
I'm consistently find it stunning and impressive how you're able to embrace your
funk had to live a life that is attuned to your kind of inner inner ripples.
I mean,
I think it's actually rather unique.
It's think it's a core strength of yours in my opinion.
I think that one element that's been very helpful in trying to mitigate the
risks and dangers in that,
in the sort of paradox of trying to be introspective while having a very public
facing life is stoicism.
And,
uh,
and I remember reading at one point,
I want to say it was Cato who is considered by his contemporaries and his
successors in a sort of stoic thought leadership to be the perfect stoic and a
lot of respects,
and I'm going to get the colors wrong here,
but he,
he would deliberately wait,
I think it was a Ballou tunic as opposed to a purple tunic to encourage people
to ridicule him because he wanted to be embarrassed about only those things
worth being embarrassed about.
So training himself not to be overly
sensitized to the critiques of the c players around him.
And so I constantly,
I remember for instance,
this is such a silly example,
but I was just in Montana,
uh,
and I went into the ski shop to get some,
some,
some light gloves just for walking around,
not for skiing.
And I looked at the whole rack and I'm like,
Ooh,
I like these.
And they were like the most ridiculous Dr Seuss,
like striped nonsense gloves you've ever seen.
Just like they will not match with anything.
Just ludicrous looking.
And I asked the woman at the front desk,
I'm like,
what do you think of these or should I get a different one?
She was like,
Nah,
I think you just get the black ones.
And I thought about it,
like I sat there,
I thought about it.
I was like,
Nope,
I'm getting the Dr Seuss clothes.
And so I got the top Sue's class.
And that expresses itself for me in a lot of different places because I will for
instance,
to do,
and this is not something I recommend to everybody.
Uh,
so caveat emptor,
you can't be,
you know,
you're in control of your whole life on life.
Uh,
so if,
if you,
if you do this,
you can face some dire consequences,
but I'll do a drunk Q and A's on Facebook and I'll have a bunch of booze and
I'll go on and I'll do a Q and a.
Something will come out that will embarrass me,
but it's not going to be life destroying,
magically create an environment in which I feel like I don't have a reputation
to protect,
which is another reason why I talk about,
you know,
the psychedelics and I'll talk very openly about,
uh,
you know,
monogamy versus non monogamy.
And I'll throw these things out here to basically ensure a,
that I never became a politician and B,
that I don't feel like I have a fixed identity to cling to that I need to
protect because I see how disastrous that can be.
Yeah,
that's really,
that's really powerful.
And the,
you know,
the fire of competition plays that role as well.
I mean,
you look at people who compete.
Let's talk about martial artists.
So,
so I own a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu school as Marcelo Garcia.
We've discussed Marcel a lot.
Definitely.
And you'd just as mentioned,
uh,
creating chaos and train yourself to operate optimally in chaos compared to
others.
And of course,
Marcello is what,
10 time nighttime,
nine time world champion is the scramble.
Yeah.
They call him the king of the scrambled egg on the screen.
I mean he's the,
he's the greatest transitional player in the history of sport.
Maybe.
Um,
he's incredible.
I mean is,
is the essence of his game is to not hold,
to allow people to move and to again embrace the chaos and get their first,
his,
he just has cultivated the transition so systematically that he has 10 in
transition where
somebody else will just be moving from one position to the next.
Does that transition itself is something which is like,
that's his ocean.
It's a beautiful thing to see.
But if you look at the school,
Marcel runs a school so beautifully and we've got at this point,
um,
a lot of world class competitors,
a lot of school tends to win pretty much all the tournaments.
A lot of the guys who you've trained with,
um,
with the Tim Ferriss experiment,
that was hilarious.
Oh my God was awesome.
We got day one.
I'm like,
okay,
I think I broke my ribs.
He did great man.
You did great.
That was Pratty.
Um,
yeah,
that you guys,
you just check that out.
That was pretty pretty.
The TV show.
If you want to see me get my ass handed to me,
uh,
and have a great time training with guys like John Tava,
who's an incredible athlete and teacher John is fantastic.
It's a TV show where checking out but I'm not,
well,
if you look at the learning curve of the people in the school,
the ones who put themselves in the line as a way of life just learn much faster
than the ones who are protecting their egos,
right?
Most schools,
what happens if someone gets good and then they have to win to PR to protect
their status as being very good or dominant usually happens with martial arts
instructors,
which is that they reach a certain level.
Um,
they opened a school,
they get a little bit older,
you know,
they get a little fatter.
Um,
they have a reputation,
so they stopped trainings that ought to be exposed by the young students who are
coming up and they sit in the sideline,
but they'd get their egos get increasingly large,
but riddled with insecurity.
And this Brittleness tends to then splay down to the students in the whole
school becomes a joke,
right?
Versus,
you know,
Marcello,
the way Marcella runs our school is so magnificent.
Everyone's in the mat training so hard as a way of life.
Um,
everyone's on a worldclass growth curve.
And it's very interesting to observe who the top competitors pick out when
they're five rounds into the sparring sessions.
And they're completely gassed.
The ones who are in the CBEST growth curve,
look for the hardest guy.
They're the one who beat him up,
who,
who might beat him up while others will look for someone that can take a break
on.
Right?
And so there's that constant search for exposure.
And if you,
and that's,
that's kind of a parallel to what you're describing in terms of not having an
ego to protect your or,
or a or a,
um,
you said not having,
uh,
yeah,
reputation to protect fixed identity,
to protect,
right.
So this is the way,
as a competitor to constantly put yourself into the fire.
Here's a question I have for you because I feel like particularly in Jujitsu,
I can get better at this.
You remember when we did that one day we'd had the key on and you're like,
Timbo,
your lips were purple.
I thought it was going to die.
I thought I was gonna have a heat stroke and have to be carted off.
But the,
uh,
do the guys,
so is it correlation or causation?
Meaning are the guys who,
who on round five pick the hardest guy in the room,
have they already self selected by coming to this school in a sense or have the,
did they start off perhaps when they walked in the door,
the guy who would pick the easiest person in the room at round five and have
been converted into the guy
who will pick the hardest person to both.
You see the boats in the latter case.
How do they cultivate that transition?
I think that Marcella was a great role model.
I think it's a good,
I mean,
that's a fantastic metaphor for life,
right?
I mean this is,
you need lists everywhere.
Hundred percent.
I mean,
I think that,
you know,
we think about this,
this principle of cultivating qualities,
the way of life and the big things and little things and you,
you look at the way Marcello runs that,
that training environment is,
is pretty exceptional.
I mean,
if people don't have the police on his ass on the line all the time,
his ass is on the line all the time.
Um,
and he's,
you know,
he's getting a little bit older.
He's,
um,
he has two kids and he's a wonderful dad.
Um,
is life is not just 100% should sue anymore.
he has all of these,
you know,
young 20s at this point.
Worldclass students who want to go at it hard with him and he goes out of
hardwood them and he wants to,
he doesn't mind getting exposed to you,
brings it.
He doesn't,
he's,
he's living it.
But he's also creating an environment where people are present to quality in
little things.
If someone is,
it doesn't have their [inaudible] on straight.
If they haven't tied their belt,
if they're sitting in a way that sloppy,
what happens does he tells them to straighten their game?
I love that.
I love that when people are running,
are doing the warmup.
If they're cutting the corner a little bit,
he tells him to run the full circle.
If people are doing a certain drill in a sloppy way,
he refines it.
So it's the,
it's,
it's the little things,
right?
And so as you watch Marcello doing the warm up,
there was a way that he'll have his hand and just brush against the mat as he
passes it.
Like you can feel him engaging his tactile feeling for the room.
Right.
You know,
when you,
he's someone who embodies and teaches qualities way of life.
So if you're in your fourth and fifth round and you are looking for a way out,
you feel that you're fundamentally violating this principle,
which you've been cultivating a tentative the school.
Right?
And,
and you know,
this is,
this is so important.
We think about a core part of how I train people is around the interplay of
themes or principles and habits,
right?
The habits are what we can actually train at that,
the principles,
what we're trying to embody.
And so we'll train it two or three or four or five habits,
which are the embodiment of a core principle.
But the idea is to burn the principal into the hundreds of manifestations of
that principle become our way of life.
Right?
And so in this case,
we're talking about Marcella talking about or embodying the principle of quality
in all these little ways,
these little ways you could say don't matter,
but they add up to,
to matter hugely.
Oh,
I think the little things are the big things.
Yeah.
Because there are a reflection,
I mean,
this might sound cliche,
but it's like how you do anything is how you do everything.
Right.
And,
uh,
it's such a,
it's such a beautiful and critical principle and,
and we don't,
most people think they can wait around for the big moments to turn it on,
but if you don't cultivate turning it on as a way of life,
the little moments there's,
and there's hundreds of times more little moments than big and there's no chance
in the big moments that,
okay,
so if people listening don't take anything else from this interview,
I think that's so key to who you are.
It's so key to why you've been good at what been good at.
That's it right there.
And,
uh,
there's a,
I'm going to hear,
let me mangle another name since that seems to be one of our themes for the
show.
This episode is,
I think it's archaeal locusts are kilocalories.
Perhaps I'm going to get this wrong,
but it was a quote gotta be a Roman,
maybe a Greek,
who knows,
uh,
who said,
we do not raise the level of our hopes.
We fall to the level of our training.
Yeah.
And if you can't just do one every five years waiting for the big event,
you're not going to have the training necessary.
Essentially
it,
you know,
as a principal that I've been thinking about a lot around parenting,
we,
you see so often people with their second child are not as present right now.
Unfortunately in today's world,
people are often not present with their first child either.
I was,
I was taking a walk yesterday with a dear friend of mine in central park and at
dusk we were just talking about other ideas we've been,
we've been thinking about and we walked past this woman who was,
had three children in,
in a stroller and was walking her dog and the children were all talking to her
and she was on the cell phone having a conversation with a friend.
Um,
and it wasn't like a quick,
it was like a long gossipy conversation and I was just watching this exquisite
external environment,
like the embodiment of distraction,
three children and a dog.
Like the children,
like looking,
trying to pull her,
but she was just in this other world,
right?
We think what the distraction of parenting and then you think about what often
happens with parents,
with the first child,
they're completely tapped in.
Um,
cause this is all new.
They're present.
And the second child they just,
um,
well relatively neglect.
We see that all the time.
Right.
I'm thinking of this luck as it were about to have our second child.
And so I'm,
I'm,
I'm thinking about like how important it is to not take for granted the things
that you've done right.
And think they'll just be there.
Um,
because they're not going to be there as in this your present,
equally present.
Right.
We think about,
and we see this in the martial arts as someone who trains twice a day,
you know,
as a way of life for 10 years,
training until they drop and doing external training as well with strength and
conditioning and stretching everything else.
And then they get to a place where they're consistently winning and then they
think they can train,
you know,
seven times a week instead of 10.
And it'll be the same.
It's not the same like that slip.
It shows there's something,
there's something incredible about going into competition knowing that there's
no way that anyone else trained as hard or as good as you as smart.
Right.
So one other than what training quantitatively,
but they were trained training qualitatively.
Right.
Um,
the confidence that comes out of knowing whether in any discipline that your
head that you gave it your all,
yeah,
when I work with someone I say that,
you know,
one of my many filters is looking at someone in the eye and saying that working
with me is,
is living as if you're training qualitatively as if in a world champion training
camp,
I'm qualitatively,
but I look at them in the eye and some people you see a fear,
you see the fear of exposure.
Other people you see a lean in an eagerness,
a game,
a hunger for what that exposure will lead to,
right.
As are two very,
very different paths.
Um,
maintaining presence to,
to that quality.
Right?
Even after we've,
we've assumed that we've got it now.
Right.
You see this with people or on presence.
You see,
there's so much bullshit in the meditation world,
for example,
last so much bullshit because people might have meditated wonderfully for four
or five years or six years or eight years and years,
but then they get ego involved with it and then they put together their schools
and they're,
you know,
they're not embodying it anymore.
Right.
And then it becomes hollow and,
um,
they've,
they kind of slipped from the philosophers of the philosopher Ologists um,
without even knowing that it happened.
They weren't even present to the question
firewalking process.
Yeah.
That's important.
What is the firewalking process?
This is new to me too.
I'm not sure I've heard you discuss this.
Yeah.
This is something I've been really for the last year and a half or so developing
intensely.
I think it's been a core part of my process for a long time,
but training people,
I've been,
I've been on this really intense learning curve and how to work with people on
this.
So the,
the core to the principle is that,
that people tend to learn from their own experiences with much more potency than
they learned from other people's experiences.
Right?
And the firewalking processes is it,
that's what I call as,
that's my term for a gateway to cultivating the ability to learn with the same
physiological intensity from other people's experiences as,
as we learned from our own.
So for example,
if you're a Jujitsu fighter and you slightly overextend your arm and you get
onboard and let's say wound jawless in the world championships,
right?
Your arm is being separated from your body,
You're,
you feel like your shoulders disconnecting,
your arms breaking.
If you don't tap,
you're going to break.
So you have the cup combination and oftentimes we'll fight it,
right?
They won't want to tap into the world.
So the combination of,
of huge disappointment,
all the,
the adrenal reactions to being caught and having been wounded and maybe torn
ligaments or tendons,
right?
Depending on how the injury sets in or maybe a bone and they will burn that
lesson to themselves and they will not over extend their arm that way again.
Right?
That's been burned in on an animalistic level.
But if they watch somebody fighting and then watch them over extending,
get cotton on bar,
that's just like nothing.
That's an intellectual knowledge that that has no impact on whether or not
they'll over extent.
But if we can cultivate the ability to learn from other people's errors or
experiences with the same intensity as we can learn from our own,
it's unbelievable how that can step in the learning learning curve.
What would be an example of that beyond Jujitsu?
Well,
for example,
a really interesting live example that I'm playing with,
um,
today is that we were working actively with investors.
Um,
is that,
you know,
we are
a brilliant investor.
Um,
recently used the term,
um,
the Pavlovian impact or the Pavlo Pavlovian influences have grown up in a bull
market,
right?
So most investors,
most relatively young investors,
grew up in a post 2008 world.
So all of their subtle,
you know,
responses have come from growing up in a bull market.
So for the most part,
they've been,
they've experienced pleasure when they put the foot on the gas and they've
experienced pain when the taking the foot off the gas for the most part,
it's oversimplified.
Um,
it's really interesting to sit down and think about all of the cognitive biases.
They,
all of the subtle associations that come with growing up in a bull market.
Now traditionally what people will say is you have to live through certain
business cycles.
You have to,
you have to the school of hard knocks,
right?
We have to learn from the pain of the other side.
But can you take a relatively highly talented young investor who has grown up in
a bull market and give them the wisdom that you think about the journey from pre
consciousness to post consciousness competitor around a certain theme,
give them the wisdom of living through many market cycles when they haven't,
right?
So then you can deconstruct systematically what does a bear market look like?
Now,
I'm not sure where for in the beginning of a bear market now,
but let's just say that we are,
we are maybe in the first or second inning of a bear market.
Now maybe we're in the tail like the eighth or ninth innings of a bull market.
Maybe we're in the ninth inning of a bull market and we're going to see some
huge round of intervention and we're going to go into extra innings of the bull
market,
right?
No one really knows.
Maybe there's some other dynamic at play.
Um,
you know,
even the great macroeconomic economists don't know,
but we,
they have a sense through deep study of either macroeconomics or valuation.
Um,
but we are at one point some day relatively soon,
we'll probably enter a bear market.
So it's going to be very important,
right?
And so we haven't lived through on,
one thing you can do is you can deconstruct what a bear market looks like and
you can have them firewalk it.
And so what that means is,
is suddenly all of the,
um,
and a bear market doesn't just mean going down.
It actually means the subtle undulation of going is often going down,
you know,
for three weeks and then a really steep two week rally and then going down again
for three weeks and two weeks ago.
So people often even bear people who are bettering think the market will go
down,
get really hurt and bear markets,
right?
Because it's violent.
It's,
it's there's a volatility to all facilities.
Yeah.
Right?
And so the question is how can,
in this case,
an investor who's grown up in a post 2008 world,
um,
firewalk market cycles so that he can burn that wisdom into himself or herself.
And then the,
the question is how you do this,
right?
And so there's a lot of the things that we discussed,
um,
around,
physiological awareness,
right?
Somatic awareness,
cultivating the sensitivity that what's happening inside of us,
right?
What comes with that is the ability to switch state emotionally adrenally.
And so if we visualize something very painful to us,
we can have the physio.
If visualize with tremendous potency,
we can have a physiological response to that.
Right?
True.
Even of exercise training people who say take a 10 meditation
visualization session in lieu of,
Oh,
there we go.
All right.
I mean it's,
we have to go pick up Jack.
We just gonna go pick up Jack,
but they can get the benefits of the exercise in large part just from the
visualization over 10 minutes.
But we have to go grab Jack and well to be continued to be continued.
Awesome.
Okay.
So we're back.
We were back,
reclaimed the boy from school eight,
some Japanese food talked about life and now here we are for the continuation
firewalking digitalization.
We're going to talk about casts.
Let's continue with firewalking.
Yes,
you were just bringing up the,
um,
the physical dynamics that are possible with intense visualization.
Right.
I had this,
this formative experience I wrote about years ago where I
broke my hand seven weeks before national championship when I was training in
Chinese martial arts,
um,
push hands and I was in a cast for six weeks,
up until I think three days before the nationals.
And the DOC said I couldn't compete in everything.
Everything's be atrophied.
But I,
but I was committed to doing it and it was really interesting cause I was just
doing all of my training one handed and visualizing the weight work that I was
doing on the one side passing over to the other,
the weight work,
late work assistance trading.
Yeah.
I was doing some work.
I was,
I was doing my martial arts training one handed,
which was fascinating on its own to just work on being able to do with one hand
what you can do it too.
That was tremendous.
But I was also visualizing the steroid resistance training I was doing on one
side passing over to the other and um,
but really intense visualization,
not just like thinking it but burning it in.
It's kind of when I explained my firewalking the distinction between the kind of
thinking about intellectually sort of trying to visualize it and then or versus
burning it in with every sort of sensory stimulation.
Yeah.
Like with your whole like spirit burning it in deeply.
Um,
and it was fascinating to see when,
when I took off the cast I had basically not atrophied and I competed the next
two,
two days,
three days later in one of the doctors.
I mean they were pretty surprised by it.
A lot of western medicine is pretty sure rise by close minded about these kinds
of things.
What
would you do to translate that to something less?
Obviously physical,
like we were talking about training people who've never been through bear
market,
right?
To have the wisdom or the lessons learned of those who have been through.
So pragmatically,
how do you stimulate that?
Do you have them interview someone who's gone through it and then try to relive
those stories through visualization or what would the pro the process
potentially look like?
Yeah.
So you just,
so
cultivation of empathy to be able to do what you just described very deeply is
one thing to be able to,
oh,
you know,
to,
to live someone else's experience profoundly.
Um,
first of all,
we have to really be clear about the distinction between intellectual knowledge
and somatic knowledge.
Right?
When we've having something burned in,
there's an adrenal response,
right?
So there's a physiology to having an experience very intensely.
We have to learn how to create that physiology,
right?
So I had an unjust,
so we can do biofeedback training,
um,
undulating between states of physiological coherence in states of extreme stress
so that we,
we build up the ability to,
to kind of move between them at will and then when we're studying,
um,
for example,
the experience of somebody getting burned extremely intensely time and again in
a bull market,
I'm in a bear market,
um,
during the volatility,
the ups and downs of a bear market,
right?
You,
you can,
you can look at it and it can feel like,
um,
you know,
just like a chart or you can experience the anxiety that comes with it.
The pain that comes with it,
the like the shattering of your previous conceptual scheme,
right?
You can almost be almost firewalk the experience of the Pavlov Pavlovian
influence of growing up in a bull market.
And then having that shattered,
you could fire walk that shattering and then open your mind to the path to the
reality of the broader cyclicality over the long term.
Um,
and there's a lot of,
I mean,
in terms of how you do it.
Well,
I mean this is the foundation is in a lot of things we've been discussing,
right?
Intense Meditation Training,
um,
ways of becoming increasingly attuned to the subtle ripples inside your body,
stilling your waters,
having a lifestyle which is less reactive,
less input addicted,
um,
being really aware of how we fill space addictively in life.
Um,
whenever there's empty space,
we just fill it as opposed to maintaining the emptiness.
And the emptiness is where we have the clarity of mind and the perception of,
of these little micro ripples inside of us.
Um,
cultivating the ability to,
to observe in us and others like the subtlest undulations of quality or a
physiology.
Will you and I talk a lot about maintaining slack?
Yeah.
Trying to
build slack into the system.
And how important that is.
And I was told by someone I respect a lot recently.
Yeah.
Find the silence because you have to listen from the silence.
And that might sound very uh,
vague,
but I found that if you really meditate on it and immutable,
it can apply to just about anything.
I mean,
if you really want to separate the signal from the noise,
you need the space to do that.
Right.
It's such an important principle.
All right,
we're going to take a baby town.
Jack is up from his nap
and her back to your regular programming.
Joshua,
we're talking about slack while this lack is expiring in the system here,
very impassioned to cries from upstairs.
Yeah.
Our,
our aim today was to do this in the morning while I'm at,
well,
Jack was in school.
I'm
fortunate.
Intervened.
Yeah.
Shutterfly plans.
Yes.
You know,
this,
this principle of slack,
um,
is a,
is is so interesting.
I mean for me a lot of it relates to the empty space for the learning process,
right?
Like in my,
in my way of life,
I'm,
I mean,
I've built a life around having empty space for the development of my ideas for
the creative process and for the cultivation of a physiological state,
which is receptive enough to,
to attune,
to tune in very,
very deeply to people,
right?
The people I work with.
Um,
and so like,
I can see how I could,
I could triple the amount of people that I work with,
um,
very easily with the systems that I have,
but my growth curve would get much.
Um,
I mean,
it would,
it would change fundamentally.
Um,
and my internal physiological training would,
would take a hit,
right?
I wouldn't have enough time for meditation,
for reflection afterwards,
for developments of,
of the,
kind of the thematic takeaways of every session that I have.
Um,
and the creative process.
It's so easy to,
to,
to drive for efficiency and take for granted,
um,
the really subtle internal work that it takes to
play on that razor's edge.
I think in part it comes back to the
limiting of inputs and selective ignorance that you've talked about,
Ryan,
because if you triple the number of clients you have in a high tech,
high tech and high touch business,
you're going to have to juggle 17 chainsaws instead of two chainsaws,
right?
Then I'm reacting,
I'm,
I'm not,
I'm embodying the core principles that we're working on.
And so much of of,
I find really high level training is kind of sort of sematic transmission.
You're embodying a certain state and then you're,
you're helping someone embody that state
as well.
Totally agree.
And I think that if you want a good example of that,
just as a relatively new dog owner or as an adult,
you can look at dogs or children who are fundamentally unblocked and that
sematic
read reading ability.
And you can see just as you said,
as a parent transmits their state of being to their child despite,
despite or with the assistance of whatever they might say.
Uh,
similarly,
if you're interacting adult to adult,
you need to sort of return to that state to be maximally effective.
And what you do in particular,
right?
Right.
And then when we're talking about sort of dancing on the razor's edge,
right?
So when you're,
when you're in,
when you're moving up the growth curve in it,
certain discipline,
there's a lot of things that you can do to reach the first,
you know,
80th or 90th or 95th percentile something.
When you're talking about the last point,
zero zero 1% you're talking
about this,
these arenas where,
where the greatest insight,
we'll be right next to the greatest blunder.
And,
and it's,
you have to be willing to go just to write on that razor's edge.
Right?
As you think about like of the,
I was having this great conversation with the sports psychologist Michael
Surveys a couple of weeks ago and he made that he had talked to uses language of
thrusting into big waves,
right?
The experience he had to go into,
like to push himself as a surfer to thrust into,
I'm big waves.
I love that.
I love that expression.
Right?
It's like,
but of course if you're thrusting into big waves,
then you can easily push yourself into the wave.
You shouldn't take,
I so big wave surfers have to be able to navigate that just the most fine.
Finally tuned
in the moment.
Just intuitive decision making process of whether the moment is just right or
whether it's a moment that will kill you.
Right?
And then if you're working with people as a coach or as a trainer,
right,
of people who are,
who are navigating that terrain,
you have to be in a state where you can have a good,
that's right.
You have to have an embodied state there.
And I think that's a,
that's a,
that's a mistake that a lot of people make and everything that they do,
they just scale.
They scale in the Lou quality.
Um,
and when they look quality,
you lose the ability to successfully navigate the razor's edge.
And then by definition you're,
you're probably more destructive than you are productive than you are helpful.
And so like when I think about training people who are in that place,
it's like 99.9% listening.
And ideally you can,
you can make the most potent suggestions with the lightest touch,
feasible.
The notes,
I took some notes beforehand.
Here are borrowed some notes beforehand and one of them touches on the principle
of scarcity
in a habit creation,
be the learning process,
see the creative process.
I don't know if we'll have time to get all of these right now,
but could you just elaborate on the principle of scarcity?
So if we think about the,
the idea of subtraction or essentialism or scarcity,
right?
Um,
I mean,
you,
you frankly are as good as it gets in my opinion,
that at harnessing the principle of scarcity,
right?
In your learning process,
learning how to deconstruct something,
focusing on what's absolutely most essential,
right,
and zone in on it,
right?
As opposed to just throwing huge amounts of resources of things and um,
just having a diluted quality of approach.
Most people when they,
when they become successful,
they have the opportunity to have more resources and they keep on layering more
and more resources on things.
And so they're not very potent and how they go about things.
If you,
if you cut those resources down 99%,
then you find yourself just zoning in on what's most essential.
And then if you can learn to add resources incrementally maintaining that
potency,
it's incredible.
You can do,
but it takes a lot of discipline to maintain that principle of scarcity.
So in habit creation,
taking on,
um,
the right amount,
not too much,
not too little,
but not too much.
People tend to
think about layering on and they get excited when they realized if I could go
through a diagnostic process was,
and then we,
we,
we realize that there's 10 areas they could take on.
They want to take on all of them at once.
Right?
You can really take on one or two things at once.
Um,
ideally one on one theme with you take on two or three manifestations,
that theme to burn that theme on and you keep on layering.
Right?
Um,
in the creative process,
I mean,
you talk about limiting inputs,
right?
We've been talking about Lynn positive constraints.
Yeah.
Positive constraints.
I mean you,
can you listen me,
speaking about this principle to you,
I mean you,
you embody this principle profound that,
what are your thoughts on it?
Well,
the few things I need just to maybe add a couple of anecdotes to what you just
said.
The first thing that came to mind was a quote,
and I'm going to butcher this,
but it's from Jack Ma of Alibaba who said,
you know,
in the beginning we had an advantage.
We had no experience,
no business plan and no money.
So it forced us to make all of our decisions very carefully.
And I do think that people tend to,
and I'm also borrowing this,
but overestimate what they can accomplish in a week and underestimate what they
can accomplish in a year,
which leads to
theoretically appealing decisions like trying to adopt 10 new behaviors at once
that are kind of,
uh,
our wise.
And you're foolish,
right,
in the sense that they're,
they're doomed to fail from the outset in many respects.
And the tea,
to your point also about scaling.
You know I have friends that call this the s word because it's romanticized kind
of
worships notion and Silicon Valley scale,
scale,
scale.
You've got to be bigger,
higher,
more people ship more product and if you are looking to kind of optimize your
craft,
your art that may or may not be the right path to doing that.
And to my mind,
you know,
you can look at exemplars or you can look at examples of people who have scaled.
We're still critics of scaling in the sense that Bill Gates I believe said,
you know,
if you add people to an inefficient process,
it just makes the problem worse.
You have to add people to it,
an efficient process.
And to that end,
like whether you are looking to build a,
for instance,
lifestyle business,
like a healthy cashflow based business that represents in some way your craft.
Let's just say you make a,
this is a real example actually like 20 customized rifles a year.
That's all you do.
And you sell to the top like 0.001% of marksman marksman in the United States.
You never ship more than that.
That's the constraint that you apply.
Whether you're trying to do that or build Microsoft,
that lesson can apply,
uh,
whether it's adding one person or adding the next thousand people.
So for me,
I think it's very easy to create a false dichotomy in your mind.
When you look at say a small still small scale craftsmen whose perhaps like
making,
uh,
let's just say
oil paintings and in rural Alaska versus a startup in Silicon Valley with a
thousand employees.
And to think of them as totally different,
but in fact,
if you look at the,
the top performers in either environment,
they'll have a lot in common with each other.
And I think one of those commonalities is applying a lot of positive constraints
even when you have an embarrassment of resources available.
When we think about this in terms of the creative process,
you know,
maybe one of the most important it's a train is the ability to ask the right
question to know where to look right.
And if you look at people in,
in most creative fields who are extremely high level of versus and granted lower
fields,
it's knowing what the most critical area is for,
um,
for thinking.
Let's pause for two minutes and then we'll continue.
I kind of want to,
Jack said to say hi to everybody is a kind of magic jack saying hi to everybody.
He's thinking we're going to get jack playing with something and then we're
gonna finish it up.
Okay.
To be continued.
Yeah,
we are,
we have dinosaur train plan for the little one dinosaur train creators.
That one's on me.
Okay.
And Josh has a continuation.
Yeah.
Thinking about this principle of,
of scarcity.
Um,
one of the,
the ways that I,
I have myself trained at this,
I'm in the creative process or harness the principle of scarcity is,
is,
and I have everyone who I work with live in this routine is forcing yourself to
end of each day.
Think about what the most important question is in what you're working.
We discussed this last time.
Um,
it's really interesting cause you're studying complexity all the time and if
you're a really high level thinking,
you're slicing through most of it like butter.
But then there's usually one or two or three years of stuckness and most people
I find tend to live in the creative process by they kind of surfacing,
deciding where they want to go,
putting their head down and just grinding their way toward it and then surfacing
later on they don't surface enough to reflect on what's the most potent
direction to go.
You think about like the human versus a computer playing chess 10 years ago now
that computers are getting really good at knowing where to look.
But you know,
10 years ago the,
the human knew that one of these two or three directions was the right essential
direction.
Intuitively we sense that,
right?
And we cultivate the ability to know where to look.
The computer.
I'd look at everything.
If we're looking at everything,
then we're just operating like really,
really bad computers.
But if we cultivate the ability to ask the most potent question,
um,
systematically,
right?
So how do we do this?
Well,
we have a routine where we end each workday thinking what's the most important
question,
um,
in what I'm doing right now.
Pose the question for the,
to the unconscious and the wake up first and the morning and brainstorm on it.
Do you have them pose it again?
No,
actually I think it's pretty important not to do that because then we're kind of
consciously ruminating on,
I have them,
hopefully they haven't thought about it for a few hours before they go to bed.
This is going to,
Hemingway wrote about in his crew and his writing process really beautiful.
Um,
the Hemingway would stop writing mid sentence.
Right.
And provide a foothold for continuing the next day.
Which we could also look at it from the framing of that internal versus external
framing.
Right.
If you're,
if you're kind of held by a sense of guilt whenever you're not working,
then you're going to feel like you have to write everything you have to,
right?
But if you're nurturing from the inside out your creative process,
you're going to be comfortable stopping with a sense of direction.
Even when you're mid sentence or mid paragraph.
Right.
When I've talked to people who have started journaling successfully for the
first time,
the can,
most consistent pattern that I see is I write less than I feel I can each day.
Yeah.
They're new.
They're never pushing to max capacity or feeling like they're pushing the Max.
They always write less than they feel they should.
Right,
right.
That's very interesting.
And if we think about taking this and then,
and then turning it into a systematic training of the ability to be potent in
the creative process,
if we're,
if we're reflecting of working on a given project and reflecting on what's the
most important question here,
and we're journaling on it,
the brains in the brainstorm in the morning and we're doing a lot of things,
you know,
we're opening the channels systematically between the conscious and the
unconscious mind.
We're waking up in the morning at the beginning.
Are they proactively,
all of these things which we discussed in the past.
But then if you sit back after,
say a month and you look back at your,
say three or four or five journals,
brainstorms Q and A's or on a given subject and you think about,
okay,
so in the moment this is what I thought was most potent,
but now I realize that this in fact would have been most potent.
What's the gap?
Deconstruct the gap between your understanding then your understanding now and
then design your training process around,
um,
deconstructing that gap,
right under and training at what that gap revealed.
It's a really powerful way for an angels.
What assumptions underlied that gap,
right?
The Krishna they cap or that blind spot,
that misperception about what was most important,
right?
Right.
And so you're training yourself day in and day out like water,
right?
To,
um,
be an increasingly potent thinker and that this is manifesting scarcity and that
we are for forcing ourselves.
No matter how many resources we have to think about what is the most important
question.
And when I'm working on right now.
Do you journal every day?
Yes.
When do you journal?
I journal.
Um,
well I general throughout.
So I was like,
I'll wake up in the morning,
meditate,
take a take a cold than hot,
cold undulation,
shower,
and then meditate.
And then I will journal.
Um,
I've had periods where I've just moved.
Right.
And especially when I was working in lucid dream where I moved straight from
sleep into and,
but that's my rhythm today.
Um,
and then when I have insights throughout the day,
I'll do quick journals about them.
Um,
and then after I have sessions with clients,
I'll do a journaling session on the most important takeaways.
Do you do that in a notebook or do you do digitally?
I do it on Evernote.
And then I tagged everything thematically,
which is hugely important for me.
I have all of my journals and all of the resources,
um,
every,
you know,
that I find valuable tagged thematically and through habits in the language of
my training process.
And so this is incredibly powerful for being able to give people resources.
For me reviewing the ideas without having recency bias impede.
Um,
now how I communicate.
Can you say that one more time?
Give.
So if I have a client who I think has to work on a certain theme and I want to
give them resources they can read on it,
I can just click on the tag on Evernote and all of the resources,
things that I've written and things that I've read circling that theme are right
there and is also really powerful because you know,
it's really hard to overcome recency without recency bias,
right?
Meaning like the primacy and recency effect.
So you're recalling what it is you read most recently,
not necessarily the best resource,
right?
And not necessarily the foundation of my relationship to the,
to,
to the theme.
Understand you want to communicate it from someone's learned from the foundation
up.
So really powerful.
The tagging,
I mean I find on,
I'm sure Evernote isn't the unknown,
not a big tech wizard as you know,
but just,
just to put this in perspective.
So we were looking for,
when we,
I'm using the royal,
we,
Josh was looking for dinosaur train for like 10 minutes,
and then he's like,
you know what,
I think I'm going to search this thing.
And I was like,
and you say you're not going to attack.
It was a good showing.
Oh,
thanks man.
That was a big discovery.
And then the like there is done this amazing how this search function works.
Uh,
should we talk about thematic interconnectedness?
Yes.
Let's talk about it.
I'd love to talk about in the context of education a little bit.
Um,
this is one of the,
I mean,
thematic interconnectedness is one of,
maybe that's the essence of my relationship to,
to the world or beyond.
Um,
I think it's,
I mean,
you and I have as [inaudible] are eccentric conversations all over the world on
surfboards and wherever else.
This has been a big topic for us,
right?
Yeah.
Constant topic in various states.
Um,
and
it's been a huge part of how I've approached learning,
you know,
from my foundation and in looking at the relationships between chess and life,
learning about life through chess than in transferring level over from chess
into the martial arts and then first Chinese martial arts,
then into Brazilian Jujitsu.
And then when I work with people,
um,
it's really how I learn and it's how I've found it's really powerful to help
people amplify their growth curves,
to teach them to be able to learn the many from the few or from the one,
right?
Learning the macro from the micro,
um,
break down the boundaries between disparate pursuits or disparate parts of life,
but between the personal and the professional,
the technical and the psychological.
Right.
Um,
and if we have an experience where,
you know,
we're on surfboards and we have some little,
thematic breakthrough and we can apply it to every other aspect of our life,
it's really interesting what can happen because we're pretty well calloused over
in our areas of strength.
But in areas where we're like less advanced W W we can be more raw and we might
be more conducive to break through sometimes.
Oh,
100%.
I mean you can see things with beginner's mind because you have no other choice,
right?
You don't have to,
you don't have to try to simulate beginner's mind because you are a beginner.
It was like the race to the bottom right.
A experience.
So for those who are wondering what the hell that means,
uh,
the race to the bottom is an expression that Eric,
of paddle will,
our Surf Paddle surfing instructor uses to refer to constantly dropping in board
size,
uh,
often measured in liters for buoyancy purposes.
And Josh and I and everyone who was there really very quickly realize that you
are,
to use your expression kind of dancing the razor's edge and trying to find a
balance between the race to the bottom,
but also maintaining motivation so you're not just slipping on banana peels for
five hours straight.
And to what extent do you focus on the board size and the race to the bottom
versus,
which gives you more maneuverability in surfing versus actually working on say
the footwork and the other technical aspects of the game on a board that you can
manage a,
and it's very jarring to think about this theme of the race to the bottom
combined with this other wonderful principal that I,
that Eric,
um,
and that we were all talking about with Eric,
which is,
which is swap the swapping of boards between.
So he had these camps where they think the 18 top stand up paddle surfers in the
world together with them all riding these ridiculously small boards that are
deep underwater when you're standing on them.
And I mean it's incredibly hard to balance in these things.
So they've internalized this race to the bottom theme so deeply,
um,
which we are working on.
And um,
and then they're also,
they had this experience where they were all together and initially it was sort
of competitive,
but then it became much more collaborative and they were just sharing ideas and
they began to swap boards.
And they began to have this interesting experience where,
you know,
every surfboard,
kind of a,
of his own lines,
right?
There's the practitioner who carves his lines,
but then there's also the board that has,
you know,
unique rocker,
we'll find new law,
new lines in the wave.
And with these guys would find is that if they swap boards,
they could see new lines in the wave because if they listened to the board,
some guys would swap boards and try to force the new boards to carve their
lines.
Others would sort of be open to what this new board could do and then they would
learn from it and then they'd go back to their board and their minds and open up
these there.
That's another way of thinking about this idea of the beginner's mind,
right?
The new board forced them,
help them see new lines if they are open minded enough.
Right?
So anyway,
but the,
this is the kind of,
this is an example of dramatic interconnectedness,
right?
So when I came back from that,
this was our last,
our previous trip where we were talking about the swapping boards theme.
When I came back and I was red hot on fire with how to apply this theme in the
investment process with my guys,
right?
So you have these teams that are so private and there are so magnificent in what
they do,
but if you could get teams to mix,
to share ideas with a sense of abundance,
right?
Um,
like for example,
if a world class portfolio managers could swap analysts with another pm for um,
a week or two or three,
would it be interesting if they were both like,
okay,
if they were truly everyone was sharing openly the,
you'd see new you'd be to do doing equivalent swapping board seeing new lions,
right?
It's forcing a beginner's mind,
but forcing the beginner's mind,
not only with an open mind in this,
but also it w tapping somebody who is truly exceptional at a very different
style of what you do,
right?
So there's an example of just having experience in surfing and applying it to
something else,
right?
And converting it potentially into a simple question,
Like where can,
where can I swap boards?
Right?
Right,
right.
Be something that is used for fodder
for people listening in a journaling exercise.
Right?
And wake up,
have your coffee or I was going to say,
have your coffee than meditate.
Probably not the right order.
Have you coffee,
sit down,
you know,
drop that question at the top and just,
we're going to swap boards.
Beautiful.
Exactly that.
This isn't it.
Magnificent journaling,
like brainstorm question to riff on.
I love it.
So how do you apply that to education?
So this dramatic interconnectedness,
I mean the way,
the way,
I don't think that we can do much more important work with children then,
um,
help them love learning,
help them learn to bring out the essence of who they are and the learning
process,
right?
So the express the core of who they are through learning,
which obviously will help them love learning and then help them discover the
magic interconnectedness.
How,
um,
the world is interconnected via principles,
themes,
people are,
are really,
um,
siloed right now.
People think about disciplines in,
in an increasingly data driven,
um,
segregated way,
segregated way in a closed minded way.
And it's kind of heartbreaking.
And so,
you know,
I have this nonprofit,
I've been running for a lot of years.
Um,
and a huge amount of what we do.
So we,
all of our work is in education.
We've got hundreds of programs around the world,
mostly in the US,
but international as well.
The Art of learning project.org is our,
is our website.
Um,
and the,
the programs that are most exciting to me are the ones where we really are
systematically working with schools to help children experience the magic
interconnectedness.
And so the way we'll do this for example,
is that we'll be working with five teachers in um,
five different subject matters or four or five or six or three,
whatever the number is in,
in,
in the same age group.
What are you smiling at Man?
So you think it was great looking at your face?
Sorry guys.
I was just looking@theurlsistheartoflearningproject.org and I was laughing cause
I remembered when we were filming the TV show and we were walking up the stairs
to the Jujitsu,
the Marcel,
I go see it Jim.
And you kept on saying towel this towel that and I thought you were saying Talla
t o w e l and I'm like what fuck is Howell?
And you're like,
it's my God damn book and you've got all upset
the art of learning.
I'm like,
how did you expect me to piece that together?
Anyway,
that's why I was smirking.
Sorry.
Right
now I know the acronym and I won't anger Josh any further and angry me.
I know it is about value with you.
So anyway,
the,
the um,
I don't remember that conversation
trying to put this up.
It was great.
Towel,
towel,
towel for like five flights of stairs.
I'm like what the fuck he talking about?
Anyway,
my bad.
So the way that we,
we do this is that we have,
for example,
five sub teachers in different subject matters working,
uh,
with our,
with,
with my team to weave the same principle of learning into,
for example,
math,
English,
history,
social studies,
volleyball,
soccer at the same time.
And so you'll have kids who are studying their subject matter,
but they're,
they're studying also the way a certain principle of learning or the creative
process of performance.
I called you,
manifests in each of these disciplines at the same time.
And so they're,
they're by definition,
breaking down the walls between these different pursuits.
And it's a really interesting systematic way of doing this,
right?
So there'll be studying the same principle in math and they moved to the next
subject and there's,
they're,
they're experiencing it through another lens and then through another lens and
they're experiencing it in sport.
Are these borrowed from the art of learning book in so much as you're talking
about smaller and smaller circles or you're starting,
you're talking about learning the macro from the micro,
et Cetera?
Yes.
Yeah.
The root of these are in our core themes of learning creativity and performance
psychology that I wrote about in my book and that I've developed since.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And we've spoken about a lot of them together.
Um,
and so it's a kind of a combination of individualized self expression.
well a lot of these themes that we've been discussing today and last time and so
can people learn more about this@theartoflearningproject.org.
They can.
Um,
so we invite every,
everybody please come check out the site.
We've got some really wonderful programs around the world and it's,
it's a good timing for this right now because I'd love it if any educators out
there.
We're on the,
on the verge of launching,
um,
about 10 really high level programs is what we want to launch all thematically
driven right now,
the,
in the next,
preparing them in the next month.
And so anyone who is in the educational world who would love to like to touch
base with us about,
um,
applying for this kind of program.
Katie on my team is can be reached@ktktyatjwufoundation.com.
I'm Jay debris foundation is the name of my nonprofit that,
that um,
houses the art of learning project.
So katie@atjtwoeefoundation.com.
Katie k a t y at JW is and Josh Waitzkin Foundation.
I'll come.
Yes.
Um,
and,
and she worked type of educators should check this out,
an email her teachers,
teachers or people running schools or school systems and the minimum number of
students or
any other parameters.
Well,
the essence of these of these programs would be,
it would be a school system that's open minded around,
for example,
engaging,
like I described teachers in different disciplines,
working at the same time in a collaborative way.
Um,
so that the kids can be embodying the same principle in,
in multiple disciplines at the same time.
I mean,
that's the essence of it.
There's a bit of a coordinated program.
We've had wonderful success doing this and it's what really excites me in,
when I think about education,
how to build systematic training in creativity through thematic
interconnectedness into the way kids learn these days.
Because kids get so excited when they can see connections.
I mean,
this is a big part of what I'm experiencing as a dad with Jack is how red hot he
gets when he can learn something,
then apply it to many other things.
This is a core part of,
of my approach to learning.
I think it's been a,
I mean it's maybe my biggest strength is the ability to find hidden harmony's
between disparate parts of life.
Seemingly desperate.
Yeah,
seemingly.
Right.
Well,
Josh,
this is,
uh,
this is always so much fun to drag you kicking and screaming out of your cage.
You did it.
Okay.
Or Cave.
I like cave more early,
cave more.
I don't know why I was thinking cage,
I guess.
I guess that's just my inner primary coming out,
but the,
uh,
people have asked me often a ballot education following my ted talk.
We're at the end,
I close out talking about tackling different facets of education and I feel like
your approach and principle based
Lens through which you can not only spot but teach interconnectedness is just so
incredibly valuable.
Like you said,
in an educational system where fields are increasingly siloed and viewed as
separate and you have political turf wars between departments and whatnot,
which only exacerbates that problem.
And I feel like this is a massively powerful step in the right direction.
So number one,
thank you for that and number two educators listening to this or if you're just
curious to check it out and it might be able to help in some way,
the art of learning project.org and then if you get a taste of that and it seems
compelling and you want to try to apply or jumped into the fray,
then Katie k t why@jwfoundation.com that Org.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
No about my bad.
You're right.
The order of learning project.org and I'll put this in the show notes for
everybody listening.
These will be,
and many of others,
uh,
many of the other things that we've mentioned will be in the show notes at a
four hour work,
week.com forward slash podcast.
But Josh,
I would usually ask where can people find you online?
But they can't find you.
So I won't ask that.
Is there any thing that you would like people to,
besides visiting the resources we just mentioned,
anything that you'd like people to take away,
consider,
do any action,
anything that comes to mind you'd like people to,
to walk away with?
Just as a closing comment
or question?
It's a big question.
Yes,
absolutely.
Okay.
It's funny,
as I,
as I sit with this now for so many years,
my primary identity was as a fighter,
a competitor.
And I've,
I've transitioned in recent years and I find my,
my primary identity now is a self identity.
The way I experienced myself is as a nurturer of,
of people.
Um,
my family,
um,
the people that work very closely with and um,
children as I work more broadly in education.
And when I think about it through the context of,
of nurturing people and nurturing ourselves,
I think that,
that we're living in a world of so much noise and so much distraction out of the
space being constantly filled,
that,
that
it's rather remarkable what can happen if we cultivate a mindfulness,
a stillness of the waters as a way of life.
And we find the beauty in that there's so much cuter than come from silence.
Um,
we can learn so much by,
by feeling the ripples of our internal experience,
um,
and his parents embodying what we want our children to him,
buddy living it,
right?
Walking the talk,
putting away our phones,
um,
living a life of deep presence with our,
with our children,
with our students,
with the people we work with,
cultivating empathy,
cultivating compassion,
um,
scares the hell out of me.
How,
how powerfully I see the world moving in another direction from this.
And there's so much that we can,
that we can learn from,
from the speed of what computers can do of where AI is headed,
uh,
of,
of what big data can reveal it.
It's thrilling to me.
Um,
as long as we stay in touch with the,
the essential parts of our humanity.
Um,
and when I experience what happens working with people,
with adults or with children,
when we're just completely present and we cultivate that presence as a way of
life,
it's incredible what can happen between people.
And when I experienced the scars in children that I see everywhere they come
from the anxiety that comes from the lack of attachment,
secure attachment,
the lack of the attunement of the parent,
the lack of the embodiment of the parent or the teacher and these things that
are spoken about.
It's,
it's heartbreaking.
So maybe I'm,
maybe I'm really,
really old school,
but there's something about,
about the cultivation of deep presence and quality's a way of life,
which just brings all through me.
And I honestly,
the other thing I'll say is that after having the experience I had a few months
ago coming as close as you can have the dying,
um,
as you can basically,
I mean,
first of all,
on a tactical level,
please,
you know,
if,
if anyone's with different forms of breath hold work,
like the Wim Hoff method,
which I think is very interesting and quite powerful,
please don't do it in any water,
even an inch of water.
Because if you go out,
you don't want to be in water.
Um,
and then
I should say,
if you practice this stuff enough and your type a personality,
you aren't going to go out.
And there's a,
it's,
it's not just a high probability,
it's almost a certainty that you're going to go out and to think otherwise is
really courting disaster.
So do not do it
in or near water.
Yeah.
And when we talk about fire walking,
right?
But living,
learning from other people's experiences with the same physiological intensity
that you can learn from your own.
There's something about when you,
when you come,
like when you go over that edge,
over that cliff,
if I could take the experience of love,
gratitude and beauty that I've been living with ever since I had that experience
and I could give it to my brothers and sisters,
you know,
holy smokes.
I mean,
what a beautiful thing.
I,
um,
and so that any way that we can,
we can just live with that,
with that deep sense of beauty.
There's a rich place,
Huh?
To find the stillness,
the cultivate,
not just fine,
but create that stillness and practice.
Like you said,
the calming of the waters I think is,
it's underestimated because of its
Percy simplicity and uh,
just as not all things that are simple,
our EEZ not all things that are simple are low in value,
right?
It's sometimes what's right in front of you within grasp that is most important
to grasp onto and make use of.
Yeah.
It doesn't have to be extremely esoteric and it's so easy to think we've got it
nailed.
You know,
like we can meditate
10 years and think we've got presence nailed.
And then we start meditating and then six months pass and we're distracted.
You know,
it,
it's,
it's just uh,
there's a constancy to it,
right?
Yup.
And a presence to the sense of the reels into danger that it can slip.
And speaking for me personally,
it's also building it in as a habit,
just like brushing your teeth for those people who brush your teeth.
Uh,
in so much as
for me,
and I know this is true for,
for many of my friends,
you can't,
it meditation doesn't really work well as a batched process.
In other words,
like meditating 10 minutes a day for 10 days is much more valuable than
meditating once in 10 days for a hundred minutes at.
And for most people it would be less painful to,
uh,
once you get into that habit and it becomes a ingrained part of your being in
your practice,
you will see the value,
particularly once you have a critical mass of,
for me it's typically five to seven days and then I'm just like,
I cannot believe I wasn't doing this.
I can't believe I stopped for four weeks or whatever it is.
It's
incredibly valuable and a brother Josh.
Thanks brother.
This was a blast man.
Thanks buddy.
Okay.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour workweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by Wealthfront and this is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive in a good way,
set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars under management.
In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why?
Why is it so popular?
Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them.
And this is because they use smarter software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams,
et cetera.
And I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they'd put you in and if you just want to take their
advice,
run with it,
do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it.
Here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular basis but normally aren't.
Great investing is a marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may or may not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of time.
Wealthfront,
as I mentioned,
since it's using software instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low costs that were previously completely
impossible right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above the first 15,000 which is managed for
free.
If you use my link,
wealthfront.com/tim that is less than $5 a month to invest a $30,000 account for
instance.
Now,
normally when I have a sponsor on this show is because I use them and recommend
them.
In this case,
it's a little different.
I don't use Wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed to.
Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of sec regulations,
companies that invest your money are not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user end have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money,
at least for me,
uh,
in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if you decide to open an account.
But just start with seeing the portfolio that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes,
fill out their questionnaire@wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim It's fast,
it's free.
There's no downside that I can think of.
Just take a look,
see what portfolio they would create for you and you can use that information
however you want.
wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim
this episode is brought to you by me undies.
If I'm not going commando,
I'm in the Andes.
I have been testing these underwear for three to four months now pretty much
every day and in fact throughout bunch of my other underwear this morning and on
the road in the house,
they are extremely comfortable.
They look good,
feel good.
They are made of micro model two times softer than cotton and scientifically
tested using the call.
Bottom method sounds very fancy of course,
and I get a lot of compliments from ladies for these.
You don't get diaper butt,
you don't get the tired elastic band.
They look great and they have underwear for both men and women.
Check out [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim and you can see everything that
I've been wearing.
They're ridiculous to the sublime.
Everything in between,
including my favorite,
which is called out.
And I would be remiss if I didn't mention their lounge pants.
This is a new thing,
and I've been wearing their lounge pants when I record podcast.
I've been wearing them out and about when I'm walking the dog meeting people for
coffee.
And they are extremely comfortable.
They're made from the same material as the underwear,
but some of them,
like the blue ones,
I have have pockets.
So you can walk about without seeming like you're off of your meds and
completely crazy.
So that is awesome.
And if you're not happy with the first pair,
you try on ice in that first of the underwear,
they'll refund you completely.
And you can keep the pair you tried on for free.
But if you're that kind of person,
you should be ashamed because that's disgusting.
Uh,
Mandy's dot com forward slash Tim,
check it out.
And until next time,
thank you for listening.
Yeah.